Welcome to this deep dive into Reza Shah Kazemi's spiritual ethos, exploring the Imam, peace be upon him, and his teaching that the peak of remembering God turns out to be a forgetting of the self.
The invocation comes forth firstly from the invoked and secondly from the invoker.
Today we are unpacking why self-forgetting is the absolute summit of remembrance, and we will finally confront what the name a person invokes truly is.
It is quite the threshold to cross.
Especially because up to this point in our exploration of the source material, the listener has been guided to build what is called a perfect remembrance.
I mean, the sheer effort required for that perfect remembrance is staggering on its own.
It really is.
It is this painstaking, lifelong alignment of the heart and the tongue.
So essentially what is concealed perfectly matches what is revealed.
You have a person who has done the grueling work of the greater striving against the ego.
They have spent years, maybe decades, taking the technical act of invocation and using it
polish the rust from their heart.
Let's linger on that rust for a second, because the text frames that impurity very specifically.
It is any trace of a wish for something other than God within your worship.
Which is an incredibly harsh standard if you think about it.
means if you are sitting there doing your prayers and there is even a microscopic part of you hoping someone notices how pious you are.
Or even if you were just secretly congratulating yourself for doing the prayer at all.
That is rust.
That is the impurity.
And the greater striving is the agonizing work of scraping that away until the heart is polished.
And when it is polished, the virtues begin to shine.
It looks like the ultimate human perfection.
It looks like the finish line.
It does.
But here is the crisis the text introduces.
The Imam says that even this perfection, this beautiful alignment where your heart and tongue are one, is not the true reality of remembrance.
There is something past it.
There is a final threshold.
And crossing it demands A profound
and frankly, shocking costs, the complete erasure of the very self that did all that work to reach it.
To the self that polished the heart.
Must be abandoned entirely.
Okay, wait.
To you, the listener who might be trying to polish your own heart, you need to understand that passing from human perfection to divine reality is not just a gradual polishing.
You do not just get better and better until you merge.
It is a sheer leap.
And that leap shifts the center of consciousness entirely away from the one who invokes.
I don't buy that yet.
How can forgetting yourself in prayer be the height of remembering God?
If the cells must be forgotten, can't a person just concentrate harder to block out their ego?
That's such a natural reaction to this.
I mean, we are so conditioned to rely on our willpower.
Well, we see it in extreme mental discipline all the time.
Athletes, ascetics, they can just force themselves to block out pain or block out distractions.
So why not just will the ego away?
It sounds plausible, but the text dismantles that idea completely.
Because there is a paradox built into the conscious will.
If you sit down and tell yourself, I am going to completely forget myself now.
You are actively thinking about yourself.
You are entrenching the self at the center of your mind.
Any effort to force yourself into unconsciousness of yourself is by definition an act of conscious will.
It is like an eye trying to wrestle another eye to the ground.
Which just builds a highly disciplined, spiritually muscular ego.
But it is still an ego.
It is the trap of trying to use the disease as the cure.
I see.
It is reminiscent of insomnia.
If you lie awake and fiercely demand that your brain go to sleep, the demand itself keeps you awake.
The mechanism of intention traps you.
So the text argues that self-forgetting cannot be an assault on the ego.
You cannot force it.
Then how does it happen?
If I can't will it, how do I get there?
It operates as a byproduct.
It is a byproduct of total absorption in the name.
All that polishing we talked about, the human act of invocation that clears the rust, it prepares the ground.
But the ultimate consummation is a divine grace that surpasses all individual effort.
You can walk to the edge of the cliff, but you cannot push yourself off.
The falling is grace.
The Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, talked about the people who experienced this.
He called them the outstrippers.
The outstrippers, like someone pulling ahead in a race.
He used imamate of a massive caravan of humanity traveling the road to God.
The outstrippers are the men and women who remember God abundantly.
And they have gone on far ahead of the rest of the travelers.
But this going ahead is not about the physical distance covered.
It is not about accumulating more spiritual miles than anyone else.
It is about the self left behind.
They have outstripped their own egos.
The early Sufi master has a reading of scripture that echoes this perfectly.
He looks at the command, remember your Lord when you have forgotten.
And his reading is fascinating.
He says that forgetting everything other than God is the true remembrance of God.
The truest remembrance requires the deepest forgetting.
And the final, most stubborn thing to forget is the you who is doing the remembering.
If we truly let go of our individuality, doesn't that mean we just disappear into the hoid?
That extinction is just annihilation into nothing.
That is the existential terror at the heart of this.
When we hear the word extinction, our biological alarms start blaring.
We think losing our individual boundary means falling into an empty abyss.
Because we equate our boundary with our existence.
I end here and the world begins there.
If I draw off the boundary, I feel like I just cease to be.
But the text asks us to look closely at what a boundary actually is.
To be an individual, a specific, limited person is inherently A negation.
A negation of what though?
Of everything else.
To be you sitting in that chair, you have to actively not be the room, not be the sky, to not be the person next to you.
Your identity is carved out by restricting yourself from the rest of reality.
So my individuality is actually a restriction.
It is a limitation.
Therefore, to negate
that limit, which is what extinction is, not a fall into nothingness.
It is the negation of a negation.
And logically, that results in pure affirmation.
The self dissolves, but reality doesn't.
The boundary keeping reality bounded is just removed.
The text gives us this governing analogy and it is crucial.
Think of God's reality as the light and creation as the shadow that follows after.
Okay, I'm with you.
Light and shadow.
If you are the shadow, you feel very real to yourself.
You have a shape, you move.
But a shadow is just a deprivation of light.
It has no substance of its own.
Now, if you are that shadow, you are terrified of dissolving.
Because you think fading away means dying.
But why does a shadow dissolve?
It dissolves because the light has moved directly overhead and banished the darkness.
Dissolving the shadow does not diminish reality.
It reveals the blinding light that was always there.
The substance remains.
The secondary consequence fades.
You do not vanish into a void, you vanish into the absolute.
The Andalusian master talks about this using the story of Moses on the mountain.
He does.
In his treatise on the subject, he examines that terrifying moment when Moses asked to see God and then fell down stunned or dead.
The mountain shatters and Moses collapses.
The Andalusian master describes A visionary encounter where he asks
Moses about this.
And Moses confirms A devastating truth.
He could only see God while he was dead.
While the individual structure of Moses was gone.
The vision of God is only possible where the self is not.
The finite structure of a human individual cannot contain the infinite reality.
It shatters it, like pouring the ocean into a teacup.
So there is a death before physical death.
The reviver jurist maps out the extreme edge of this process.
He calls it the extinction of extinction.
Okay, we know what extinction is.
The fading of the self.
What is extinguishing the extinction?
It is the final trap of the ego.
In the first stage of extinction, the self goes quiet.
The noise stops.
But if the soul sits there and realizes it is quiet, if it is conscious of its own unconsciousness, it is still observing itself.
There's an observer saying, look how deeply I am concentrating.
Look how quiet I am.
Which means the ego is still there, just hiding in the observer's chair.
So the extinction of extinction happens when the self becomes unconscious.
of its own unconsciousness.
The observer is severed from the observed.
The text mentions the loneliness of unconsciousness as a prerequisite here.
You have to surrender your comfortable, self-satisfied intimacy.
You have to give up the warm feeling of being a pious person who is doing a good job at praying to taste the true intimacy of remembrance.
That brings up a massive structural problem, though.
If the human agent is entirely gone, if the self is erased,
The observer is gone, who is doing the remembering?
This brings us to the grand inversion of the entire process, and it is the core of the Imam's teaching.
The invocation comes forth firstly from the invoked and secondly from the invoker.
It flips everything upside down.
Let's unpack the order of being here.
Usually we picture prayer as a creature standing on the earth, calling out across this massive, silent void, hoping to reach a distant God.
We think we're starting the conversation.
We think our voice is the origin point.
The reality is that God's remembrance of the human being precedes the human's remembrance of God, and not just chronologically, but in the.
fundamental order of existence.
How does God's remembrance function as the origin?
Think about creation.
God's creative word calls the human out of nothingness.
Before you existed, you were a possibility known only by God.
The act of holding you in existence moment by moment, giving you the breath to even form a thought.
That is the primary invocation.
God remembering the creature is what allows the creature to exist.
If God ceased to remember you, would simply blink out of being.
I see the inversion now.
The capacity to call out was the first gift.
Our human response is just the shadow of God's prior call holding us in existence.
The breath you use to say the name is borrowed from the source.
To understand the mechanics of this, the text introduces another vital image, the clear mirror.
So we are back to the polished heart.
The human invocation is merely the reflection thrown back into the mirror of the heart.
Now, think about a flawless mirror.
When you look into a perfectly clean mirror, you don't see the mirror itself.
You don't see the glass.
You see the glass, it means there are smudges or scratches on it.
But if the rest of the ego is entirely gone, nothing of the glass intrudes.
Only the face is seen.
To remember God is to step out of the way.
It is to let God remember himself, holding creation and being
to the very creature who previously thought they were the one doing the work.
That sounds like wordplay isn't calling a St.
one of God's names, just blasphemy dressed up?
Yeah.
Especially since the 6th imam who denies the name is the named, argued explicitly against this to prevent people from worshiping 99 different gods.
That is the ultimate friction point, and it is a brilliant question.
We are talking about total absorption in the name, but we have to ask, what actually is the name?
Is it just an arbitrary human label?
Is it just a sound we invented to point at the sky?
Or is it reality itself?
If the name is the named, as the Sufi maxim says, that feels like a collision with the warning from the 60 mom who denies the name is the named.
The Andalusian master resolves this by showing us that the word name operates in two entirely different senses.
If we conflate them, we end up in heresy or a totally hollow theology.
Okay, let's look at the first sense.
The name as a conceptual boundary.
In the first sense, the name distinguishes specific concepts.
The merciful is a different concept than the all-conquering.
Knowledge is different from power.
In this conceptual realm, the 6th Imam who denies the name is the name is absolutely correct.
The names cannot be identical to the essence.
Because if the concept of mercy and the concept of power were both literally the essence, you would divide the essence into pieces.
You would shatter it.
You would have 99 different gods, which would completely destroy Tohid, the indivisible oneness of the divine.
So conceptually, the names must be viewed as distinct from the essence to preserve that oneness.
So that is the first sense.
The conceptual label is not the name.
What is the second sense?
In the second sense, the name is identical with the reality itself because these are not human labels.
They are divine self-disclosures.
God names himself.
The reality of the name is penetrated by the substance of what it denotes.
To invoke the name, then, isn't just shouting a label.
It is laying hold of the reality that disclosed itself.
The text says that every soul comes into being through its own specific divine name.
The divine support shaping your existence takes the form of your human possibility.
It adapts to the container.
Which gives us our final governing image, water taking the color of its cup.
This is how the one reality expresses itself through multitude.
Water in its pure essence is shapeless and colorless.
But if you pour pure water into a red square cup, the water appears red and square.
If you pour it into a tall blue glass, it appears blue and cylindrical.
The water hasn't changed its fundamental nature.
It is still pure water.
But it takes on the determination of the vessel.
The name is the light, the soul is the cup.
The divine reality remains one, but it fills the exact contours of your individual existence.
But how do we actually access that?
How do we move from the sound of the name on our tongue to the pure water inside?
The Fatimid poet philosopher maps this out through the dynamic of the outward and the inward.
He says every outward word, every physical thing is a husk.
A protective shell.
Containing an inner kernel.
intellectual and spiritual labor is passing from the husk to the kernel.
This passage is the inner interpretation.
It is the active tracing of a thing back to its origin.
If you just say the name without presence, you are just chewing on the husk.
You are just moving your tongue.
To invoke it fully is to follow the word back to the source that disclosed it.
is letting the outward name return to the inward source.
So we are weaving these two mysteries together now.
The mystery of the self undergoing extinction and the mystery of the name returning to its source.
And they converge perfectly in the figure of the friend of God.
The saint who has actually undergone this process embodies both truths.
This is where we encounter those shocking sayings in the text from the sermon of the clarifying declaration.
The statements that sound
impossible for a creature to make.
The Imam declares, I am the gnosis of the mysteries.
I am the face of God.
I am the mirror of God.
If you only hear the husk of those words, it sounds like massive arrogance, a creature claiming divinity.
It sounds like an ego trip, but the text clarifies that these sayings are the exact opposite of self-dishification.
They are the expressions of a perfected servitude.
How does claiming to be the face of God equal servitude?
The Persian poet gives us the lens for this.
He writes, I am a shadow, the sun is my lord, I am the chamberlain, I am not the curtain that prevents approach.
The friend of God reflects the divine names precisely because their own ego has been completely annihilated.
Their emptiness is what allows the reflection.
There is no private individual ego left to appropriate the glory.
The eye that speaks those words is not the limited historical person.
That person has undergone the extinction of extinction.
The greatness expressed is the divine expressing itself through a vessel that has entirely stopped claiming ownership of its own actions.
We are back to the clear mirror.
The mirror loses its identity when the eye fixes only on imamate within it.
The mirror doesn't cease to exist physically, and God remains God, totally independent.
But the friend of God is the clear mirror where the face is seen because they no longer draw any attention to the glass.
The effacement of the self yields the perfect reflection of the divine qualities.
It is the ultimate paradox.
The deepest effacement of the self results in the most perfect flowering of human virtue.
We think of virtue as something we build, like a muscle.
But here, true virtue is what shines through when we finally get out of the way.
The fundamental realities of mercy, justice, compassion,
They aren't human traits.
They are divine names reflecting in a polished heart.
And they shine undimmed in the friend of God because the rust is gone.
The text points out that the saints' hearts are already in paradise while their bodies labor in this world.
They are enduring the physical gravity of the material world, but their consciousness is relocated.
Although the text doesn't gloss over how physically agonizing that relocation can be,
Operating a biological body while your center of consciousness is absorbed in the absolute creates massive strains.
The system overload.
The text documents the profound awe that caused the imam to frequently collapse in the palm orchards of Medina.
He would fall down, completely dead to the world.
Observers genuinely thought he had died.
It wasn't a medical condition.
It was the sudden overflow of a soul so absorbed in God that its ordinary biological consciousness just shut down.
The human nervous system cannot endure the uninterrupted weight of the infinite.
It is an awe that just short circuits the body's protective mechanisms.
It is not a fear of creatures where you run away to protect yourself.
It is a terrifying, overwhelming awe of the real, where you flee toward him, abandoning everything else.
He was continuously living that death before death we talked about with Moses.
His whole life was a preparation for the final dissolution of the shadow.
And the ultimate seal of this teaching were the theology
reality locked together is the historical account of the imam's physical death.
Struck down by a poisoned sword while in prayer.
An incredibly violent attack.
The kind of sudden strike that would trigger the ultimate biological panic, the final ego defense in any normal human being.
But his cry was not pain or anger or despair.
His cry was I have triumphed.
He had triumphed because the final boundary was being removed.
The shadow was finally completely swallowed by the light.
And with his absolute last breath, his
tongue was still moving with the invocation.
The breath and the name became indistinguishable.
He spent his final moment on the testimony of oneness.
There was nothing left in him but the remembrance.
The clear mirror was taken aback.
The invocation comes forth firstly from the invoked and secondly from the invoker.
Given that the height of remembering God is the total erasure of the one remembering, which of your own deeply held spiritual practices or remembrances are still secretly serving your own self-regard?